[Music]
well hello they are watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages
time to see what is making the headlines
with christopher hope
chief political correspondent of the
daily telegraph and jessica elgot chief
political correspondent at the guardian
welcome to both of you and with us right
through until midnight
so let's see what is on the front pages
then starting with the i
it leads with tonight's news that the
rules on who must
isolate after being pinged are to be
changed
to keep the economy on track the daily
mail says there's increasing
pressure from business for the changes
many top firms have signed a letter
from the paper to that end one mp has
called for the army to be brought in to
make sure there are no shortages on the
supermarkets
that as you can see is the main story
for the metro front of the telegraph
then a study has found that sending
school children
home after they come into contact with a
covid case is
unnecessary and that daily testing would
be just as effective
the guardian reporting on rising anger
that a 3
pay rise for nhs workers will have to be
funded by the service itself
the deliverer returns to the
disappearance of toddler ben
needham in greece in 1991 with an
artist's impression
of how he might look today and words
from his mother
who still believes he is alive the
financial times leading on the results
of an inquiry which is found that
financier lex greensell
had privileged access to ministers and
to david cameron the sun says footballer
harry kane is to leave tottenham hotspur
for
manchester city for 160 million pounds
and a wage of four hundred thousand
pounds a week
while the star is worried about the the
welfare rather of the education
secretary who it seems hasn't been
around for a while
some holidays and all that i guess um so
let's talk more then to
christopher and to jessica welcome to
both of you
right so the news tonight then uh is
that there are exemptions
quite a long list in quite a large
number of sectors
um jessica what will this do do you
think and will it calm
the demands for change and uh they're
bringing forward of that august the 16th
date
yeah i mean there's still tory mp is in
pretty much open revolt
over this policy and demanding that the
policy
that you can avoid um isolation if
you've been double jabbed been be
brought forward from
from august 16th you know it's just
mounting hundreds of thousands of people
having to isolate
tonight the government's announced that
workers from 16 key
services including things like health
transport energy
won't have twice that of being pinged
but there are very very serious caveats
to it
you've got to apply via your workplace
you've got to be a named person who gets
a letter saying that this particularly
applies to you
and it certainly doesn't apply to all
workers within each of those sectors
only the ones who are doing very
critical work which they can't do from
home will it apply to so the
government's tried to make this very
very narrow
and and you know one might say difficult
to use
because otherwise the case would be why
not just stop it i guess
christopher well yeah i mean the
politics here is that it's a lock down
without calling it one it's that without
one being mandated by the government so
they're using the the ping and the
sensitivity of the ping
which won't change and the august 16th
date far away when pcr tests will give
us a true freedom they're using
um this this ping and this and these uh
i mean listen to uh jess speak then it's
like hearing something from from common
communist uh russia where he applying
sectors can apply
names people only i mean crumbs we've
got a tory government in power
you wouldn't believe it would you give
them what this this virus has done to us
but you know this is the way the
government's going to do it they don't
want to lock down any further
that's the political dividing line so
they're allowing the ping
to take all the strain yeah i mean it's
not a lock down though is it we're not
living as if we're under a lockdown
this is just unnecessary public you
heard boris johnson say this is
you know about the only thing that's
left in our armory partly because they
got rid of face masks i guess
christopher
some people feel they're locked down
certainly looking at the numbers um who
are being forced to sell fireside after
being pinged i mean
it must be well nearly towards 2 million
now given it was
600 000 in the past week yeah it's not a
lockdown in that sense but it's because
the government
has reached the end of the road with
lockdown certainly that we as jeff says
there with his own back benches
there's at least there's more than the
42 required to overturn a vote in
parliament on vaccine passports
that's that's the next fight coming in
our paper in this story here in the
telegraph that i've helped right
we've got our lord lanzi andrew lansley
backing jeremy hunt
saying bring forward the august the 16th
date when a pcr test if you're double
jabbed
will get you back into the workplace and
i think that's where it's going the
question is can the government
hold the line for long enough for to
stop that being a big issue but pressure
is growing on that date
yeah and you do wonder if they're
actually worried about testing capacity
if cases do indeed rise up to about a
hundred thousand
there's got to be pressure on that um
but you know it's it's it's pictures
like on the front page of the metro
isn't it with those empty
shelves which to be fair are not
universal uh we have to bear that in
mind
appeals for people not to panic by um
ping in the army
uh one suggests you know how close are
we to some sort of crisis point jessica
well supermarket leaders who met with
the environment section george eastern
tonight say that that that that we're
not at that crisis point at all and
there are some you know the these these
shelves seeing these shelves i think for
a lot of us
is very emotional and very scary because
it reminds us of the very early days of
the pandemic where
you know you'd walk into the supermarket
after work and just have nothing to buy
and that it really did
you know i think we it's quite easy to
forget how scary that felt
um for a lot of people and i think
seeing this again
um is very evocative of that supermarket
leaders say that that's not
you know that's not the case and in fact
sort of supermarket retail workers
aren't even going to be covered by this
scheme it's all about food supply
workers
um that that should be you know getting
this this stuff to the stores
christopher you wanted to come in then
well i'm trying to
try and look closely on my screen here
that appears to be water
water shelves and i don't know what how
your day's been anna but i've been
roasting today no wonder the water's run
out i mean i wonder whether that's
actually caused by this
um pink demigods just basically a hot
day
and they're low on water but i mean jess
is right he's making a broad point here
there's also there is a brexit angle and
just might enjoy this working for the
guardian
but there is an issue here with um a
driver shortage which might take
five months to clear because of problems
with eu workers getting to the country
and being able to drive vehicles here
so i think it's a bit of a kind of
perfect storm
hot weather forcing water to run out an
issue with eu drivers and
drivers in this country combined with um
the pandemic and people being pinged
yeah you're suggesting that if that was
the uh the ice cream shelves
it would be the same situation i guess
aren't you well exactly
i'm always a bit loathe to trust i mean
metro is a retro paper and i'm sure
that's not the case but i just do wonder
sometimes
whether the pictures are forgetting
what's happening in the outside world
it was boiling today and yeah
oh you've momentarily frozen uh we went
through parker today that's the royal
week it wasn't me by the way and uh it
was all fine so you know i think it's
where you are isn't it and certainly
some
holiday resorts seem to be uh worse off
but you know don't panic by
the goods are coming is the answer but
we're going to go to uh christopher's
paper but jessica you'll have to do it
while we reestablish
oh you're back hello you keep freezing
we can hear you spit like radio to be
honest with you
um which is the story in the telegraph
about
schools and what to do about them
obviously um schools have broken up the
bubble system has gone anyway
but this is a study which has shown that
actually testing can
stop the need for being sent home for 10
days jessica
then on the face of it obviously it's
it's quite a heartening study
um you know that's found that if you if
you do test
children every day going into school
then you know
you can have the same effect you prevent
um outbreaks in the same way as you do
sending them home i mean this year has
just been an absolute nightmare for
parents who've got
children in school and for children
themselves you know there are so many
teenagers leaving school who might have
had their their last few weeks of school
just cut
short leave as assemblies things that
you know really mean something and
really matter to people and
i think the government's pretty in you
know pretty set on
those kind of bubble systems isolations
won't happen from september
um i know a lot of school teachers are
preparing for them
for that to be have to be reintroduced
anyway you know they're having that
basically as their plan a
and plan b is going back to normal just
because you know things do seem very
uncertain
and at the moment we're supposed to be
pressing ahead with exams
um at the end of next year even though
the children who will be taking those
exams might have had their first year of
studying
you know incredibly disrupted um and so
you know i think a lot of teachers are
quite apprehensive about the year ahead
but this hopefully
should be some reasonably positive news
yeah and just a quick thought from you
about this christopher's it's it's
your paper obviously we know a million
children were out in uh one of the last
weeks of terms so
so many who've been their final years of
either primal secondary would not have
said goodbye to their
fellow students it's really it's really
tough for people isn't it
so what i mean who knows what will come
because the cases could still be
really high when schools go back in in
the start of september
yes second second july that we've been
through this my children went through it
last july
and it's really really sad they miss out
on something yes there's a problem here
um and i think we'll be living with the
virus as we all think that now don't we
from from september i mean this is a bit
a bit off the event this research if any
would known about this as the start of
the summer term
they may have had rethought the bubbles
and rethought the wisdom of sending
children home
when as as this study found out 98.4
of children who were sent home for 10
days never went on to develop kobit
why were they sent home why we i don't
know what we're doing really better than
kids home because
they they need to be at school they
should be at school and it's i think
we've got a bit mad at this really and
it's important
that come to come the next academic year
the next one
we get this right now christopher hope
chief political correspondent of the
daily telegraph
and jessica elgot chief political
correspondent at the guardian
let's go to the financial times shall we
uh picture up the top there
olympic games officially starts tomorrow
um jessica are you looking forward to
this are we all just watching what might
happen
yeah i mean amazingly enough i i it
it feels like it's kind of really crept
up on us there's usually a massive build
up to the olympics and
and just because it's always just been
so tentative about this going ahead
it feels like you know the fact that
it's starting feels almost almost
dreamlike i mean it is
it is certainly you know one of the most
kind of
precarious games that that any of us can
can can ever remember i mean
you know in the middle of a global
pandemic how many you know 11
000 athletes um more than 200 countries
flying into a
city which is in the state of emergency
and a
city country where you know there's not
a lot of the population are fully
vaccinated i think it's only about
20-25 um and where you know that that
poll after paul says the country doesn't
want it where frontline
medics are saying please don't come
we're having to divert vital resources
it's it's a terrible shame for the
athletes really
to have to to have to come into an
atmosphere like that
but i suspect a lot of them would not
want you know their olympic dreams
postponed again and you know for many of
them that might mean not being able to
achieve them at all so it's a very
difficult dilemma for them and it will
be an incredibly unpredictable
game yeah let's go christopher let's get
to your store if you don't mind in the
daily telegraph which is about
pay this the backdrop obviously is the
nhs pay award
what's happened to the police what's
happened to teachers what news do you
have about mps
well what's quite interesting i mean
today was the last day of the house of
commons sitting before september
um and so jess and i well we can put our
feet up maybe but not really
um ipsa the independence expenses
watchdog
is is suggesting that it has more power
to
move mp's pay up or down above above and
below
public sector pay it's been linked to
public sector pay since 2015 to try and
remove the politics of mps
voting for a pay rise um but the concern
here is ipsa are saying they may want to
go above public sector pay now what they
say to us
is that's very unlikely ever to happen
but the fact that put out this
ipsa consultation in the week when
you've got police getting
zero you and nhs nurses getting three
percent which some would say
is quite generous but the private sector
pay but not enough for them
possibly i think it's it's further it
just shows how this whole area is toxic
and it could be a problem for the mps
yes indeed so um quick 30 seconds if you
don't mind jessica
on the picture in the metro of festival
goers returning
yeah and you know i even though i i
think people are feeling quite nervous
about
you know apprehensive about the case
rates it's cheering i find it cheering
to see
you know people so excited having fun
back in a kind of like
young people just i feel have just
missed out on so much and have made so
many sacrifices
and if this kind of thing can be done
safely it will be a real
joy and and hopefully you know a real
lifter to everyone there i've loved
going to festivals myself and i hope
that everyone
can do it safely and have a really good
time oh indeed so jessica elgot
christopher hope
thank you very much indeed